[Music]
[Applause]
we had Will Ferrell on yesterday and we
were trying to plan a trip to Dublin a
couple of years ago and we thought okay
let's maybe try to do it next year it's
Navy Notre Dame in Dublin and then Will
Ferrell says I'm all in and will went to
USC he said hey I'll go but I can't root
for Notre Dame I got to root for Navy I
said that's fine and uh then we put it
out on social media and then I saw were
Brady Quinn commented that uh basically
sang and I'm paraphrasing oh is that the
same Will Ferrell who heckled me on the
sidelines when Notre Dame played USC so
we thought well you know give you equal
time here Brady Quinn joins us now the
Fox Sports college football analyst uh
what do you remember about Will Ferrell
on the sidelines when USC played Notre
Dame well I remember it pretty vividly
um this this guy behind our bench who
kept yelling hey 10 10. your parents are
too high your pants are too high and I
remember like kind of turning slightly
in my backup at the time Tabby goes dude
Will Ferrell's yelling at you who I was
like Will Ferrell the actor I turned
back and showed up your pants are too
high and I stood up and I thought
man my pants are kind of high right now
not a little bit I mean I've always had
longer legs and short torso but I really
never became self-conscious about it and
so Will Ferrell pointed it out so as as
like great as Matt and Reggie were I
think part of the tough part about going
to the Coliseum was dealing with Will
Ferrell heckling you and not being Star
Struck by it did you say anything to him
no we're going to say to Will Ferrell I
mean it's not like you're going to have
a better whip than he's gonna have and
we're getting our ass kicked at the time
so I was a little more I kind of
conscious of that I think I had
separated my shoulder that game
um and I'm pretty sure we like Tyrone
Willingham that was in the Coliseum my
sophomore year so 04 and I was pretty
sure like it was gonna get fired after
the game so I had a lot more going on
inside my mind trying to talk trash back
and forth with Will Ferrell have you
crossed paths with Will since then uh I
don't think so I don't think so would
you like to go to Dublin with us when
Notre Dame plays Navy
and you could join
myself the dance and Will Ferrell it
would be the trip of a lifetime I'd be
incredibly honored uh I do have some
requests though
um for starters I think Guinness is
involved in this so I would have to you
know be a part of that somehow I love
Guinness it does things different over
there okay so that'd be part of this and
I would have to be strategically
positioned behind will so I can
absolutely wear out both ears throughout
the course of the game as Notre Dame
Stomps out Navy in that matchup
would you wear high pants though
I probably would upon arrival and then
before I go the opposite
maybe I don't wear any
of this well
take it too high if you don't wear any
Dan he'll challenge you since we saw him
in Old School he has no problems taking
off his pants that is true that is true
yeah you're not there's no portably
challenging Will Ferrell so I I think
maybe on the way in you wear them high
see if he says anything and maybe he's
like oh I remember that guy he's the
high pants guy like I remember that guy
Brady and uh Fox's big noon kickoff crew
will be in West Lafayette and that uh
Penn State Purdue Thursday night
coverage starts at 7 Eastern while I
have you Notre Dame Ohio State and I
don't know if your reaction was the same
as your head coach when you saw that
Ohio state is a 17 and a half Point
favorite against Notre Dame
yes it opened at 13 I think so that
number is climbed
um I won't ask everyone out there hey do
you guys happen to remember I know
you've got a lot of help there in Studio
Dan what was Oregon last year as an
underdog going into Columbus uh early in
the season you guys had 14 and a half
that kind of kind of like ringing in my
ears
Polly will look for that
yeah
um I was there for that game though we
were in Columbus and I think it was as
surprising as as anyone watching Oregon
run the football down Ohio State's
throat and what do you have Paulie organ
at uh kickoff was getting 11 points okay
yeah
it was surprising to see Oregon play Big
Ten football
in Columbus
yeah and and I think you know people can
say well that was early in CJ Stroud's
career he threw for over 400 yards in
that game yeah passing attack wasn't an
issue
um they fly out got beat they were out
schemed defensively uh they didn't make
adjustments and I think you could look
through the course of the season last
year and go look at the Michigan game
Michigan ran for what almost 300 yards
and that loss in Ann Arbor you go look
at the Rose Bowl versus Utah Utah rush
for over 200 yards against them so
that's why they brought in Jim Knowles
as defensive coordinator who by the way
that scheme didn't hold up too well
versus Notre Dame the bowl game so it's
a bit surprisingly because I think
there's some question marks about Ohio
State more so than people want to
recognize and um Notre Dame's got an NFL
offensive line bottom line they probably
could be the more physical of the of the
two and that's what I I expect to happen
is try to control the game of the
rushing attack you know look clearly on
defense you get your hands full with
Jackson Smith and jigba CJ Stroud and
the wide receiver group but if you can
limit a big place shorten the game you
know limit Ohio State to 10 11
possessions and and play good red zone
defense and you know by eliminating some
of those big plays you're gonna be right
there and hanging in that game with a
shot to win if you ran Nebraska let's
say you're Trev Alberts you're the
athletic director at Nebraska at what
point do you think and I still think
there's high hopes for Nebraska all
those transfers so maybe you know they
figure this out but if they don't at
what point
could you see them or would you make a
change at the head coaching position
you know it's an interesting question
and we we talked about this this morning
on FOX Sports radio and one of the
things I kind of posed was if the
transfer portal existed when Scott Frost
first took over
how fast would he be able to change over
the roster to what he was looking for
because you really couldn't for the
first couple years few years he was
there and I think part of that is he you
know he's got Equity within the
university because what he did as a
player but not so much what he's done as
a coach and that's why he's kind of on
that leash right now with you know all
the staff changes he made offensively
coming into the year and now Mark
Whipple you know turning over taking
over
you find yourself in a position where if
he could turn it over faster would they
would be talking about Nebraska a little
bit different I mean you know Palma for
example did a transfer wide receiver
both had big games they're a big part of
the game plan offensively Casey Thompson
looked phenomenal in the first half uh
all those things you're looking for on
some of those transfers to help kind of
create that change they're there it's
just going to take time
um it's tough you know I hate you know
first off I love Scott Frost you know I
think anyone who sat down with them
talked them about ball
um you like his demeanor you understand
where he's coming from I just think that
job's a lot harder than people realize
coming into it you know very similar to
Jim Harbaugh taking over Michigan I
think people act like he was taking over
the job from Lloyd Carr that wasn't the
case you had been through a number of
head coaches to get that thing to
transition to compete with Ohio State
Scott Frost is doing the same thing you
know this isn't the 90s Nebraska team
that we recall seeing
um and so it's going to take a while to
get not only through the portal but I
think recruiting and everything else the
way they needed to be and honestly
probably moving on from something the
guys he was close to on his staff might
have been the best thing for him so now
they can all kind of hold each other
accountable even though his post game
press conference uh comments might have
made some waves
we threw this email
Urban Meyer
back in the Big Ten
would he be welcomed back to coaching
back in college
I I don't know you know I'm not sure I
haven't I haven't talked to enough
athletic directors of people in the know
about that yeah obviously he's been the
most successful head coaches in college
football history you know winning three
national championships doing you know in
two different eras BCS and the college
football playoff and at two different
conferences and I think that's one thing
that kind of stands out when you compare
what he was able to accomplish as a
college football head coach compared to
some of the other greats is when you can
do it in different conferences like
understand what it takes to win the Big
Ten understand what it takes to win the
SEC and to win a National Championship
at that at that point it's it's it's
completely different and so
um you know could he go back and kind of
bring that back to Nebraska I don't know
okay more likely to go back into
coaching John Gruden or Urban Meyer oh
geez
um
let's see how old is grew in 59 he's a
year older than Urban yeah that's what I
was going to say I mean they're both
pretty young uh I I don't know I think
they who knows if they both I mean
obviously John Gruden wants to he's been
public about that yeah I think it more
depends upon
what you know if you want to Pro if you
want to be the team in the University of
providing that second chance right like
that's what it's more about who's gonna
put their their name and reputation on
the line to provide him a second chance
to go do it
um and that really probably stands for
both but there also has to be a desire
to do it you know I I don't I don't know
that coach Meyer wants to I'd have to
you know talk to have that conversation
uh I haven't had that conversation with
him this year uh before I let you go
you're off the board Super Bowl pick so
we're looking for Value here oh gosh
nothing obvious
um well that's that's the hard thing
like what's Bengals well the Bengals
were not obvious yeah well I got a lot
of flack for throwing the Jets uh under
the bus earlier this this uh this spring
and summer I should just say the Jets
and so everyone's gonna be so confused
yeah but you don't believe that oh 100 I
don't
okay can I say the entire AFC West like
I would say right now do like a parlay
bet them all together I don't know how
that would work out but but whoever's
going to represent the AFC okay so you
boxed the AFC West correct and if okay
so I don't know if you can do that oh
you could do that Dan you could do
pretty much anything these days
well uh I'll let you know about going to
Dublin next year at this time
please do I I would I would love the
opportunity I'm very honored to receive
the invitation sure and uh how much time
to get back to my homeland and anything
to get back for a second I thought
you're talking about Dublin Ohio where
I'm from
Ireland that makes sense do you have an
accent because we're demanding that
everybody who goes has to be able to say
you know have have some kind of accent
there uh when I get drunk yes okay great
it comes out and naturally comes out all
right like my grandpappy all right uh
yeah because Patty Fitzgerald just
brought you know Northwestern back there
so we had him on yesterday
yeah all right I like that it takes it
takes a few beers
there'll be a few of those uh thank you
Brady and uh have fun in uh Wes
Lafayette Indiana will do thanks
everybody that's Brady Quinn former
Notre Dame quarterback the uh big noon
kickoff
I got the Penn State
all right we're I think we're getting a
caravan here